okay welcome back to the 2021 fall
season of the corporate chess league it
sounds like we had some technical
difficulties so you might have missed
our lovely intro that we did i was just
saying we've got a huge matchup in round
one between enterprise and worldwide
technology are two leaders of the league
so far in overall points
and we're taking a look at this game
here between dv dutch playing for
worldwide technology with the white
pieces and chess hulky with the black
pieces and i was just saying that uh we
had some interesting tactics going on
white had just played this move knight
d3 uh trying to save the rook from a
certain death with this bishop on a6 but
then he gets hit with this move rook d8
just a simple skewer here and it looks
like white's losing material that's why
db dutch went for this move knight f4
but chess holkey seems to be putting him
away this move queen to b5 now there's
simply two threats in the white position
and i don't think you can stop both of
them so
good start for enterprise here with
chess hulky
having a dominating uh position so far
okay continuing on let's check out
sweetman against moneyballin sweet man
playing for worldwide technology we got
money ballin on the enterprise team
and wow we've got a rook in g2 uh the
rook is just just in there
and to my eyes it looks like it would be
good for black but we've got some pieces
hanging very complicated position here
um overall if if black keeps everything
together he's going to have a few extra
pawns at the end of the day i'm thinking
we can just take this guy over here on
b2
swing over with the rook and black is is
in good shape so
so far so good for uh enterprise i've
looked at three boards and it looks good
for them on on all three
uh continuing down the list we've got
derrick for free playing for worldwide
technology up against kendalum for
enterprise
and this position looks a little bit
more tame uh derek for free seems to be
sporting an extra pawn here that's
always nice
um and the two bishops yeah looking
looking all right for derek for free not
a huge advantage but it is an extra pawn
and a comfortable position with the
bishops
and actually yeah we we do see a
resignation already in this game between
dv dutch and chess hulky so early lead
now early lead for enterprise in this
match
and then the last game to look at in
this matchup is going to be gerald
zelsky up against 21 gigawatts uh
gerozzolski playing for worldwide
technology 21 gigabytes on the
enterprise team
and wow this game
is i think it must have gotten started a
little bit later than the other ones but
it's underway now a little bit earlier
on in the game and white's now breaking
with this d4 move trying to open things
up for this bishop
now normally i'm going to advise caution
for white in positions like this you've
still got this king in the center of the
board so you got to be a little bit
careful about offering to open things up
here it looks like it's it's fairly
under control white has such a good grip
over the center over all these light
squares
that uh i don't think the white king is
going to be in any danger and we do just
see now d takes on e5 i'm expecting the
pawn to recapture i could consider
taking back with the knight trying to
put some pressure here but i'm a little
bit wary of just leaving this diagonal
wide open
you know come to think of it i'm also a
little bit wary about leaving this
bishop wide open over here as well
but
we'll see what they have in mind see
what they have in mind anyone's game
uh in this one
all right let's circle back around to
this first game because i don't know if
those tech issues were fixed when i was
first looking at it but we've got mjc
for worldwide technology kamikaze knight
for enterprise and things have developed
in this game
when i left it i was just saying that
white is probably going to be a little
bit better here we see this pressure on
the queen side this unopposed bishop is
going to give bl white some advantage
maybe when then black hit back with a b5
trying to lock things down a little bit
plant a knight on a good outpost a4 is
not allowing black the opportunity b4
and then ooh bishop takes a6 is a
sacrifice uh so we see what black
captures two minor pieces in exchange
for a rook and white gets these two
pawns in return so now the question is
going to be are those pawns worth it we
see white doubles goes queen b4 brings
this rook in
and yeah a very interesting position
here
i have to say i think it is still
looking good for white
these two minor pieces they aren't badly
placed per se but they don't seem to be
you know doing too much you know what is
this bishop here on f5 actually
accomplishing what is this knight in e4
accomplishing and this knight on c4 is
actually going to get kicked away and
wow now the knight on e4 also getting
kicked away none of these knights are
going to be stable in this position and
because of that
still looks good i think for kamikaze
knight
okay so
with that i think in almost every game
uh things were looking good for
enterprise the only
uh positive note that i could see for
world wide technology was that game with
derrick for free if i can find it looked
good for white here still looks good for
white derrick for free actually picked
up another pawn this pawn on c4 has just
disappeared
what happened to it
well fair enough white went up and over
and just took that pawn
so two extra pawns now for derek for
free and looking good
uh with that in mind why don't we check
in on this match between bayer and
doherty we have vindy here board one for
bear up against darty and what happened
in this game we got a slightly weird
opening vindi i think uh pretty much
every week has been playing these these
very cagey openings not striking in the
center too early and then we see this
really interesting break of b5
i don't think i'm on board with this b5
break see whenever you have these
fianchetto bishops the a1h8 diagonal is
the important one for black and black
has already ripped this diagonal open
now conversely for white you're gonna
see this uh h1a8 diagonal be really
really important that's the diagonal
under white's control so b5 is kind of
just helping white activate this bishop
along this diagonal i see no reason why
white wouldn't want to take on b5 even
take twice on b5 take on e5 get threats
against this rook and i think black is
in pretty serious trouble here so
good start for doherty if c-cell can
navigate those complications
um and
if i can get back to the position what
happened we saw a trade a trade and yeah
takes on b5 so pretty much what i
expected would come to pass has happened
now white's just gonna have some
comfortable extra pawns here
okay let's continue on we've got
alamaxia on board two for bayer against
dardy and alamaxia does seem to be
getting it done uh much better position
than vindy two extra nights i expect
oh no this is something 70. elemexia is
black okay well that's two
good positions for darty and then the
last game we're going to look at there
is going to be tyler brock meyer up
against i love legos 2.
uh tyler brock playing for
bayer and i love legos too of course
playing for doherty a regular at this
point with an unforgettable username
uh and what's going on in this game
this one also seems to have gotten off
to a little bit of a later start than
the other ones
and again it's going to be a big center
for whites we just saw white play this
move c3 supporting these dark squares
and black's pawn on d5 is not going to
survive for too long here white's going
to take it or black's going to take on
c4 and white's going to have a pretty
nice edge in the center look out for
bishop takes h6 sacrifices as well these
could be right around the corner with
white just crashing through on the
king's side
excuse me so it looks good for bayer
so that's two games a little good for
darty one game that looks good for bayer
and that is where we stand there
so with that quick look around
everywhere let's just jump back to our
board one match up see what's going on
here this is a super interesting
position between mjc and kamikaze knight
with that sacrifice of two pieces for
the rook
and yeah now we're gonna see white's
pieces start to invade
that being said though with this last
move bishop h2
i'm wondering why not take this why not
take this pawn
i
guess mjc was worried about the move g4
i guess g4 was the concern
it sort of felt like you got to take
these pawns before
before it's too late but yeah now bishop
e5 this is
potentially giving black an opportunity
to try and invade over here but yeah mjc
has just fallen into this habit of
responding to threats and some threats
you just can't respond to now i think
white does have a knockout punch here
with rook to c8 afterward to c8 what are
you going to do with this knight just
what are you going to do you can't move
it out of the way otherwise the queen
comes through on f8 support of the rook
and you can't even defend this knight so
looks
very very difficult now for
mjc to get back in this game
the question is though is kamikaze
knight going to find it is he going to
find it
we shall see
yep three minutes on the clock is gonna
be plenty and he comes up with rick c8
now this queen e2 idea is actually just
gonna be too late uh queen e2 white can
still just capture on e8 you don't even
have time to take this rook because
you're just getting checkmated basically
now it takes b3 it's also going to be
too slow just captures here cannot take
this rook because of takes and takes
queen f8 now
is close to checkmate queen f8 f6 rook
c7 and that's game over okay just queen
f7 as well no reason to allow f6
and that's the game so good start for
kamikaze knight
um
let's check out uh board number two here
what am i looking for i am looking for
uh dv dutch dv dutch lost his first
match against chess holkey they are well
underway in round two and let's just
stick with this position a little bit
because it also looks very interesting
how did we get here
okay we had a d3e4 a king's indian
attack type setup
and we see
quite slowly but surely
i think trying to advance on the king's
side yeah something like that in these
positions you would normally expect um
let's see you would normally expect what
you would expect this bishop to kind of
drop back
and oops i guess i can't play moves
um let's say you would normally expect
this bishop to drop back and white to
try and expand with the move like f4 in
this position uh chess loki went for a
different approach trying bishop f4 then
dropping back
and now we've got f5 by dv dutch so f5
f4
and this is where things currently stand
uh with white jumping out to attack the
queen black responding with this f3
check and boy oh boy what is happening
here okay we have a queen sacrifice
so black took a bishop took a rook and
now we'll take a knight
uh totaling 11 points
of material in exchange for the queen so
that's actually gaining material believe
it or not despite sacrificing the queen
dv dutch has just gained material now
the downside is
it did cost you some time to take all
those pieces and now white's ripping
things open on the king's side so really
anybody's game here this is going to be
an interesting one for sure i'd be very
nervous about capturing this pawn on h5
you have a lot of loose pieces and you
have a loose king over here
the question is though what do you do if
you don't want to take how do you invade
with the pieces is knight f4 too slow is
rook f6 and rook f8 too slow i'm i'm not
sure here this one looks quite dangerous
looks quite dangerous
and dv dutch is going to take his time
here while he sorts this one out
the more i look at it the more i think
we do just have to capture here and then
thanks to our pieces we do have some
coordination play something like knight
g7 response to queen h5 and i'm actually
covering quite a lot of squares around
my king this knight supports the bishop
the bishop supports my knight and then
after that i'm gonna slowly but surely
ramp up the pressure and come after your
king here on f2
yeah dv dutch takes the other approach
he goes bishop g3 right away and this
looks tempting to try and counter-attack
but when you have this many pieces on
the board it's less about making threats
right away and it's about making sure
all of your pieces are very very stable
so i'm not a huge fan of this move
because it makes this bishop just less
stable now queen g4 is going to be
attacking a billion things at once and
you have to work very very hard to keep
everything together so keep that in mind
when you have a lot of minor pieces
against a queen you want to make sure
they're all stable they're all very safe
and that's what
takes a knight g7 would have done would
have kept this knight safe kept this
bishop safe kept this knight safe and
then that gives you the freedom to bring
the rest of your pieces into the game
that's what coordination is all about
bishop g3 and yeah now queen g4 comes on
the board chess hulky knows what it's
about
he knows what it's about
and now
what to do
what to do you have to deal with this
you have to deal with this you have to
deal with this rook takes f2 is legal
but it's just a check and even if you
pick up this bishop
the rest of your pieces are are
suffering for it they're suffering
so in this case i think i'm i'm starting
to go back towards liking the the extra
queen here
liking the extra queen it's a useful
piece the queen it does a lot it does a
lot
and big news
kamikaze knight did win that game as
expected uh kenjalum has also won
against derrick for free which is
a
big result because that was one of the
the boards that looked good for
worldwide technology
and then ends up going to uh to kendram
instead
ends up going to kendalum
okay we do see rook takes f2 king g1
and i think
black is is pretty much gonna have to
take over here
maybe there's some really weird knight
f4 idea but it looks a little bit
artificial i don't think this is going
to be the way to go
for black
the
third option is to kind of try and
ignore everything just play something
random like uh like rook a to f8 but i
don't think the threats are there to
justify it you're gonna get checked
you're gonna lose this guy you're gonna
lose this guy with check
you get check check and take
not looking ideal
not looking ideal
i think you have to take on d2 i'm just
i'm not very happy about it not very
happy i think black is going to be
losing some pieces here
i think some things are going to fall
we'll stick with it though because
things are still in tension here and i
want to see
what these players come up with
what will they come up with
yeah rook takes d2
and now you are spoiled for choice with
white which of these pieces do you want
to capture i'm thinking you got to start
with the knight oh no he takes with the
queen
yeah i don't actually know about this
decision this one feels a little bit
wrong to me now i can save my knight
with knight g7
chess hulkie is probably planning an
eventual
h6 idea to threaten checkmate ooh but
king h8 is also a very nasty idea
believe it or not the idea of king h8 is
to defend this bishop on g3 due to the
threat of rook g8 coming in
yeah i think queen g6 was by far the
worst of white's options for for
capturing there
um now though queen e6 is is a counter
trick if we go rook g8 that's actually
checkmate in one
very dangerous stuff going on very very
dangerous game
um now if i'm black i'm again i'm
looking for that stability i'm looking
for moves like bishop e5 moves that put
all my pieces on squares where they're
defended so i just know i'm not about to
blunder the game away
that's the idea here
you can maybe throw in a check if we're
really interested
yeah i think the big issue now is going
to be that dv dutch is is running out of
time here gonna be running out of time
okay we got bishop e5 on the board
okay queen h6 now king g8 you're gonna
hit okay queen king h1 cannot be right
now
the checks are gonna start flying the
checks are gonna start flying
and yeah tv dutch this is the
opportunity to make a comeback here this
is the opportunity
yeah rook g8 now rick h1 rick a1 is
going to pick up a rook
you have to be careful though of this
checkmating threat you might have to
throw in a rook f8 check here or
something like that
very dangerous stuff very dangerous okay
rook f8
now if came back to g1 we might actually
see a repetition in this game believe it
or not
might see a repetition
hmm i wonder if there's some way for
black to uh to deviate here but i don't
know it's it's looking very dangerous
very risky to just not accept this
repetition the king is so so weak here
and if you do anything else
uh white might be the one that starts
giving checks
yeah okay king g1 and rook back to g8
okay maybe
maybe you can go rook g2 here
maybe you can get away with it ah just
rook f8 instead with the clock situation
i don't think this is a terrible idea
that being said though the match
situation is is not looking great for
worldwide technology so they really need
every point they can get here
so if dv dutch thinks he has a chance to
win it might be worth taking
might be worth taking that chance
chess hulky now is uh
if if i know chess loki he's thinking
about king e1 he's trying to uh
trying to get him trying to get him
he sees the clock situation and he's
thinking if he can deviate and score an
extra point for his team
yeah and he does wow king e1 is bold um
probably too bold that's just checkmate
that's just checkmate so
you know greed is sometimes good but in
this case chess hulky gives the game
away with king to e1 and that's that's
just not it that one's gotta sting a
little bit that one's gotta sting just a
little bit that's checkmate
wow what a game
what a game that one was
um so with that let's actually click on
over and check out our current standings
if we can
and looking at it it looks like even
though uh dv dutch did win that game uh
yeah if i'm doing the math right
enterprise has officially already
clinched this match moneyballing got it
done with a quick 2-0 and with all their
other players scoring at least one point
that's going to be enough to take the
match victory so enterprise defends
their lead against the number two
challengers
with that in mind i'm going to start
focusing more on this bayer doherty
match
if i can
so who's playing in that we've got vindy
up against c cell 0 6 0 3. looks like c
cell did take the victory in that first
game we saw him playing some impressive
chess ripping open the diagonal for his
bishop
in that first game getting it done
okay what's going on here we've got uh
vindi with the white pieces
trying to to make a comeback and it
looks like his position is going to be
pretty decent here um he's going to be
trading on g7 i think can't really get
away with saving this bishop and i don't
see any other tactics so we're probably
going to see bishop takes g7 here
then
we kind of have a problem with this
knight jumping into e3 but overall it
looks like white's going to have pretty
good control over these key central
squares just play something like queen
to e2 hit him with h3
uh and oh
yeah after f5 it looks like white is on
the offensive but black is gonna be
jumping in with knight to e3 and it
looks a little bit scary here looks a
little scary
um yeah that's just going to be in
exchange that's just going to be an
extra exchange
so vindy had a good position out of the
opening but just missing the the simple
tactical threats it's going to be tough
i think uh vindy was actually trying to
trap this knight over here on g4 with
this move f5 but that's a bad miss
and looking good for c cell
okay if we can switch over to
tyler brockmeyer it looks like he
actually has won his game against i love
legos 2 so they will have to play a
rematch
but uh bayer's hopes and dreams are kind
of resting on tyler brockmeyer here he
seems to be the only one that scored any
points so far we've also got alamaxia up
against something at 970. we saw
something 970 with a big win
in
uh round in the first game of the round
so al maxia trying to fight back here
and we've got another super tactical
position
we just saw rook to g4 get played kind
of a weird move but the idea of leaving
this rook under attack is that white's
going to take back with the bishop give
check to this king and also attack this
rook on a8 so white would be getting the
material back if black chooses to
capture the stroke
and in the meantime we've got some
dangerous looking threats over here the
bishop is attacking on the king's side
we've got these two major pieces lined
up against the g7 pawn
okay h6 is trying to kick some of those
pieces out
um and i wonder if white is thinking
about some sacrifices here something
like
rook takes on d7 queen takes on e5
and wait whoa whoa no that's just a
tactic just rick takes d7 is is good
rick takes d7 is good
i think that's the end of the story if
you take back
i actually take on f6
and you are in
trouble wait but that's not the end of
the story you have queen takes g4 in
that position
is it true
my god the tactics just keep flowing um
but
again the time control is only 10 plus
zero so you have no extra time added to
your clock every time you make a move
and looking at the clock situation
alamaxia's clock is definitely ticking
down here
very much ticking down so
if he can't move fast enough then uh
then he's going to be in trouble by the
way i did the calculations i ran the
numbers i think this tactic is is good
you have queen takes g4 here uh now
putting the queen under fire so if you
were to take back
then black would be able to take the
white queen and end up up in exchange
but in that position after queen takes
g4 there's the amazing move queen takes
on c6
removing the queen from the throat of
capture with pressure on the rook on a8
and
that would be a winner i think no way to
save both the rook and the queen white
would end up winning in that position
instead uh alamaxie goes for a different
move order he spent the remaining time
that he could afford to spend but
couldn't come up with the correct move
that's just just unfortunate had a
dominating position there but couldn't
quite get it done
couldn't quite get it done
okay
so with that something 970 is almost
certainly going to be winning this game
as well
and with that
it's all down to
this vindie game if vindi can hold on
here despite being down the exchange
bayer has a chance to tie the match
unfortunately their hopes of winning the
match are rapidly disappearing uh if
alamaxia were to lose that game that
would be
that would be the end of that story
pretty much so
we've got knight d5 here it's not
totally hopeless for
uh for vindi
not totally hopeless
he is down the exchange but again he
does have really good control over the
light squares in the center so he's
coming in now with this bishop out on d5
a very solid outpost for it
and if you're going to save this game i
think you definitely you got to start
launching some pawns on the king's side
white needs to get something going over
here
needs to start attacking this king take
advantage of the fact that this dark
squared bishop is missing it's a good
score good source of compensation so if
i'm white i want a pawn on h6 and i want
a queen on g7 and i want to declare
checkmate
now it's obviously a little bit of a
a little bit of positive thinking um
it's going to take some work to actually
get that done
but that's the idea
yeah this move c4 i'm not super thrilled
with
in a position like this i want to keep
my pawns back a little bit and i want to
use them to make sure i can lock the
position down keep an eye on some of my
dark squares to compensate for the fact
that i only have a light squared bishop
c4 now this diagonal is going to be
wide open for this queen to start
invading on
and once black starts getting counter
play over there it's going to be tough
going to be tough
that being said if this queen were to
leave a little bit too early maybe we'll
see some kind of f6 idea and uh threats
on these dark squares
okay queen d7 instead and i'm not sure
i'm in love with this movie either again
we're looking at these f6 ideas
okay e6 was the point i i just missed
this move yeah e6 and now this bishop's
trapped another reason why this move c4
just felt a little bit wrong
okay white's not throwing in the towel
though white's saying if you take my
bishop i'm gonna try to check me too so
very important here i think that this
king goes to h8 rather than g8 why is
that well if you go to g8 i go queen e3
queen h6 and there's nothing you can do
to stop queen g7 if you go to h8 and at
least against this you have rook g8 to
sort of uh calm the storm
to keep your king alive for a little bit
longer now white's still going to be
coming in with moves like rook f4 and
rook h4 to check made on h7 but that's
going to take some time and with that
amount of time i think black should be
able to maneuver his way into the
position and and keep things
under control
so king h8 it's do or die now for vindy
you've got to try and go for checkmate
um but it's it's probably not going to
be working in the long run there are
some very tricky ideas though so
definitely gotta invade on those dark
squares
how to invade on those dark squares
uh queen g4 is a nice idea actually it
preserves the bishop for another moment
at least but i don't know if that will
uh
that will keep it safe for forever i
think yeah it's still just gonna get
gonna get captured so clever idea but in
the end
it's all gonna be the same here uh you
just gotta go for this checkmate
you just gotta check me at the guy vindy
cross your fingers
and hope for checkmate
okay queen h4 i don't actually like this
move as much as queen g5 because now
black has the opportunity to play h5
i'm not sure if it's correct but it it's
just another way for black to try to
keep you out of the game
okay we do see queen h6 now rook g8 only
moved to stop checkmate
and now you got to play rook f4
and after rook f4 i'm i'm very curious
if
if black will be able to spot
the the idea
maybe you can there's an argument for
playing rick f3 but i think rook f4 is
your best shot and i'll explain why if
if we see it ah okay yeah
takes on d5 is way too slow now you're
going to see this queen invade come into
h5 and wreak havoc
here's the trick though if i were
a dirty swindler i would play the move
rook f4 and the reason is um let's say
uh black plays some kind of slower move
like queen e6
yes i have rook h4 here with a nice idea
but i also have queen takes h7 king
takes h7 and rook h4 checkmate just
immediately ending the game
so really nasty stuff that being said
against rook f4 i do think black has
this move
of g5 so maybe rick f3 was a bit better
yeah actually rook f3 and i'm not so
sure what what black is doing you
probably have to sacrifice your queen
here to stay in the game but yeah takes
on d5 is going to be way too slow oh my
god i say that but then this move is
just a howler like yasser would say
queen takes e4 you cannot play that you
have to have to have to go queen h5 here
get this queen out of your position now
rook f4
we saw a check
and that idea that i mentioned just
might crop up here
it looks like tactically though uh white
black did find a way to hold on for the
moment queen e3 check and that sort of
pin
along that diagonal and okay maybe maybe
black's play is not quite as bad as i
thought although
yeah looking very scary like there's
your h4 ideas um queen e5 is going to be
enough to get out of that one though
but it's definitely scary stuff that
being said it looks like c cell does
have it under control
just barely
just barely
okay so with this
i'm not going to call it just yet
because it's definitely possible to
blunder checkmate here but with this win
uh c cell would secure the match victory
for doherty
so we get queen e5 check and yeah no no
time on the clock vindy loses
loses by clock but yeah just imagine
just imagine
the the shock and horror if rook f4 here
queen e6 takes takes queen or rook h4
checkmate that would have been would
have been one for the ages
um okay though with that we have i think
um matches are pretty much decided
everywhere so if we take a look now at
the results
um we have uh edward jones securing
victory against ascension alex curford
heading up the
edward jones team gets it done with a
perfect 2-0 and now even if oak ave is
able to win his last game for ascension
that won't be enough to win the match or
tie the match we do see enterprise
securing match victory against worldwide
technology moneyballin and kamikaze
knight with the clean sweeps securing
that victory for them
and then finally doherty is going to be
winning uh against bayer
if vindy could have pulled off some sort
of checkmate there there was a hope that
tyler brock could get it done again and
tie the match but that hope is now gone
with doherty securing match victory
so with that why don't we take a look at
our remaining games looks like we have
21 gigawatts up against geraldzelski
um okay there's not much to see here
black has an extra queen we also have
oak ave against fishers of men oh and
this one does look very very dangerous
uh black has the extra queen
but i was i was gonna say white has a
rook and a bishop for it but that bishop
did just die
so not so uh interesting anymore this
pawn is going nowhere king e7 and the
pawn will not survive
still king e7
and the pawn will not survive okay
uh making it tough now rook f8 and white
is going to be getting a queen as well
okay rook c8 and white is also going to
be getting a queen
although wait a second
this is this is checkmate yeah you had
to go rook f8 check
otherwise rook c it would have been good
oh but the checkmate was missed
will black be able to find it with 10
seconds on the clock queen e1 you have
to go g6
no he's not finding it he's repeating
moves
he's repeating moves
and that's a draw that's a draw just
could not find g6 check here when the
white king is busted
so last second draw between oak gav and
fishers and men really crazy stuff okay
and that leaves us with our last game of
any of the matches
tyler brockmeyer against i love legos 2.
i think they got started a little bit
after the rest of the players so their
game is the only one remaining
um and it looks very good for tyler
brock meyer um he did his best did his
best for bayer but even two points is
not going to be enough to
level that match
um so how do you go about winning a
position like this well you've done the
hard part you've got the extra pawns now
all you have to do is push them up the
board so yeah get the bishop out of the
way start pushing these guys forward and
above all else please please please do
not hang back rank checkmate
um if you do then you might have to quit
chess just out of shame just just out of
shame
so hoping that no back ranks uh happen
here today
white of course
sees the opportunity is gonna give it a
go rookie one threatening rookie eight
you can play rook to b1 here white's
probably gonna play bishop c1 renewing
the threat but yeah
not mad about h6 just give your king the
flight square and now you can't lose
rook to b1 is going to be good as well
just trade off uh when you're up
material
and yeah just push the pawns that's all
you got to do here
push the pawns forward
like the game kind of plays itself from
this point on not many ways that this
can go wrong here
yes hello to adi in the chat thanks for
joining thanks for joining
and i
don't think we are
publicly alive yet i think the us
championships is still going on but when
they do wrap up we will be
going public with some more viewers
hopefully
okay we are in a more basic endgame now
black did end up losing this pawn on c2
but that's not going to make a
difference now we just need to push the
pawns in
okay h5 is
making things more complicated than they
need to be that that would have been a
pawn on g5 that would have been a pawn
so if i'm black i'm not really worrying
about these pawns on the king's side i'm
going king d5 and i'm i'm pushing my
connected past pawns down the board
push the connected pass pawns
uh tyler instead is going for another
pass pawn over here on the king side a
little bit a little bit unnecessary to
get the third pass pawn rolling but it's
going to be good enough
going to be good enough here
there's just not much you can do here
with white
you can try to put this pawn here
go for some kind of trick by winning the
a7 pawn but it it seems a little bit
far-fetched
okay yeah could go for f3 now but now he
is switching to the good game plan
uh just in general when you have bishops
of the same color like this you want to
generally put your pawns on the opposite
color and the reason for that is if we
have our pawns on light squares
then the squares we need to control are
actually going to be the dark squares
and our bishop is going to help us do
that whereas if we were to push through
on the dark squares you can imagine this
king lands on c lands on d3 it's gonna
be hard to get to kick it off right if
we go here
super easy to kick that king off
and yeah tyler doesn't know doesn't know
his end game theory gotta go with the
light uh the light squares okay king d1
is also not putting out much of a fight
had to try with with uh
with king to d3 here that being said the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
the position is going to be winning no
matter what
no matter what
uh you can imagine bishop c5 here and we
actually might get a checkmate with this
bishop a3
we might end up with checkmate
and we are we are going down that path
okay king c3 instead doesn't spoil
anything
um
does prolong the game slightly though
yeah but now white white can't stop
everything
you just can't stop everything here
it's kind of interesting black is
playing this position as if he didn't
have a bishop and he's still
still
making a lot of progress here but uh
yeah if you look at how black has played
this it's sort of like the bishop didn't
exist right he just sort of pushed with
the pawns and the king alone
um kind of funny but it's enough
it's enough
okay last hope for white is stalemate
tricks gotta play h4 if you're a big
time swindler gotta play h4 here but
yeah not even h4 and queen a1 sacrifices
one queen checkmate with the second and
that is the end of our first round of
play
nothing left to look at
so let's jump back over to our pairing
sheet here and take a look at the final
results alex gets it done for edward
jones with a quick 2-0 uh justini
linguini splits with gilmore 999 and
fishers of men we saw with that crazy
draw in the final minutes of our round
uh couldn't find that last checkmate to
get the extra half point
no matter though edward jones wins the
match and wins those uh all-important 20
grand pre-points for edward jones
we have worldwide technology against
enterprise worldwide technology put up a
fight but kamikaze knight proved to be
too strong on board one with that 2-0
sweep that put
worldwide technology very far behind in
the match already money ballin also
really getting it done with the 2-0
sweep
a little bit lower 21 gigawatts i think
is a new competitor don't recognize that
username from the past couple weeks
and uh good start for 21 gigawatts with
the one and a half points
uh moving on down the line we also took
a look at the bare darty match we saw c
cell playing some pretty impressive
chess here
able to
defeat vindy in two straight games and
then we saw alamaxia who had some crazy
crazy tactics that almost turned the
tide against something against something
970 but at the end of the day almexia
was a little bit too short on time to
find the craziness and lost tyler
brockmeyer getting it done though for
bayer it just wasn't enough
darty wins the 20 grand prix points and
in our extra section we saw
some games between cross to pj and nikez
and nmc chin against number seven
and with that that's going to take us
into round two what's going on in round
two uh-oh
uh-oh it's enterprise it's edward jones
it's the match-up of the knights look
out whenever these two teams play of
course these are the only two teams to
win in the corporate chess league
overall
enterprise and edward jones and i have
to say the lineup tonight i think it
might just favor enterprise on the top
couple boards kamikaze knight and chess
holkey seem to be on pretty good form
tonight kamikaze knight especially
playing some very impressive chess alex
is going to have his work cut out for
him
um a little bit down the line though
this is where edward jones i think is
going to pick up some points moneyballin
had 2-0 in the first round there but
fishers of men i think is going to have
the higher rating a little bit so
definitely a lot to look for in that
matchup
and then looking even further down we've
got worldwide technology against bayer
so worldwide technology going to be
looking to come back after that tough
loss to enterprise i think that's
actually
the first match they've lost in the
season i think
i might be wrong on that but i think
that is the first match that they've
lost so far
we also have ascension against doherty
uh
on
uh
the other boards and i think with these
matchups we have nobody in the extra
section that doesn't happen every day so
everybody is fighting for their team in
the next round
and looking at the clock it's 702 it
looks like we are just about ready to
get underway and
just like that games have started so
we've got uh justini linguini up against
chess hulky let's see what's going on
we've got d4 c4 uh queen's gambit
declined
oh and knight takes on d5 not the most
common we'll see what black has in mind
and wow yeah black is playing early
queen b4
very very weird stuff in the opening so
uh why don't we see knight takes d5
every day normally you want to take back
on d5 with a pawn and the reason for
that is what you're seeing right now in
the game white just broke through with
e4 and is going to have a little bit of
a space advantage in the center whereas
if you had a pawn here on d5 that would
be a little bit harder to achieve
because the pawn could always capture if
you break through
on d on onto the e4 square
so white now going to be playing for
that space advantage in the meantime
though chet silky does have himself some
nice squares with this knight on d5 i
would have been a little bit wary of
playing this move so soon if i were
white because i think after knight to f4
this bishop would be a little bit stuck
and that bishop is an important piece
for white that being said i don't like
what chess sulky did he captured on c3
which is only going to fortify white's
center
and let's see what happened from there
okay yeah white broke through with e5
again might be a little bit early for
this move although actually never mind
it's just tactically winning i just e5
and bishop h7 and there's no defenders
on that square
now though the reason why you don't want
to play e5 too early is if this knight
can stay here on d5 it's going to be a
good outpost it'd be a very good outpost
for that night
and yeah again i find myself disagreeing
with the way justini chose to go about
things here i think you have to go c4
here otherwise
moves like g6 looks scary for black but
they might be uh might be real threats
but yeah i would have much preferred c4
kicking that knight off the d5 square
although now we see chess loki is moving
it to f4 willingly trying to threaten
some kind of g6 if i had to guess
um that being said though i think knight
f4 is kind of asking for it i think
we're gonna see queen e4 land on the
board and
stuff like queen h4 knight g5 are gonna
be gonna be coming in
okay just g3 is going to kick the night
out as well not a bad move
by any stretch
yeah i have to have to like justini's
position here so good start for edward
jones on this board let's check in on
board one just getting underway between
kamikaze night now it's we'll let them
play a few moves before we check back in
moving on to board three we've got
moneyballing for enterprise against
fishers of men for edward jones and it's
going to be a queen's gambit accepted
okay
so we're going to see a similar kind of
structure to the previous game where
white is going to get the central pawn
duo
now the key here for black is going to
be
striking back in the center you have to
play a move like c5 here to challenge
these pawns in the center if you don't
you're going to be a little bit cramped
and actually in the game knight c6 i
don't think is the right way the right
way to go
uh white broke through with d5 but i
think e5 would have been even stronger
what's the point well the point is white
uh black actually doesn't have this d5
square we could just capture capture and
then we have a super strong pawn on e5
and not such a great structure for black
okay instead though d5 is not bad
and yeah now we're going to get a little
bit tactical here a little bit tactical
okay we see a bunch of trades
and then i'm not actually sure
sure about this position uh black chose
a more conservative way to go played
queen d6 stepping out of this pin he was
worried about this knight but this pawn
on d5 is is very very weak so definitely
double-edged position
all right continuing on we saw a trade
in rookie 7 and yeah i think white is is
sort of getting away with it here it
felt like at some point there black
might have had an opportunity to uh to
win a pawn in the center
but
uh yeah now i i think with the rook
activity it's gonna be good enough for
uh for white
okay now with black after d6 you can
take on f3 take on f3 take on d6 but the
white rook is able to capture on a7
so nothing doing here if i had to guess
i would say the objective evaluation is
a draw
but with all this activity you might see
moneyballin come up with something here
you might see him come up with something
so now you could play rook takes a seven
i would actually be tempted to just slot
in this move rook to d1 instead
the reason being i just want to activate
the second rook
so yeah rick a7 instead but now what i
was worried about is actually this move
rook to c2 all right if i'm white i want
to play rook to e2 i'm not super worried
about losing a pot or two here i just
want to keep the black rooks out
yeah so b3 keeps the pawns but now
you'll see some activity starts to come
and once this once both these rooks are
active it's going to be white who's on
the back foot so
always remember in the end game
activity is usually more important even
more important than material
even more important than the material
okay continuing on down the line who
else is playing in this match
um
let's see we have kendalum playing for
enterprise against miquez for edward
jones let's take a look at that game
and oh right off the bat looks good for
kendall look at all this space on the
king side look at all these threats
around the black king
you have to work pretty hard here not
not to mess something up with black that
being said
for the moment i don't see the
breakthrough i don't see the
breakthrough and in the meantime slowly
but surely black is going to break
through with b5 i like this move queen
e7 though it just makes sure everything
is super super safe
uh before getting getting crazy
elsewhere
so something like queen e7
maybe he wants to play rook b7 first if
you don't play rook b7 i'm actually not
super sure how you ever play the move b5
okay looks like mikez is just giving up
on the b5 idea trying to get this night
out like this but queen h5 poses some
problems now you have to deal with
queen takes h6 and with the pressure on
the rook that's why you see the move
king to f8 a little bit curious though
what do you do
against queen g6
i don't think you have a move
that's why i wanted to play queen e7
just wanted to keep things a little bit
more safe a little bit more solid than
this because now
i do think that
it's going to be rather dangerous rather
dangerous for for mikaez i think queen
g6 is just winning material i think you
have to go back with king g8 and then
queen g6 is good
okay rook s6 instead feels like slightly
the wrong move but white is just going
to build the pressure absolutely there
was a nice tactical
blow there that could have
been found by pendulum but the slower
approach is also going to leave you with
a very good position
okay so looking good for pendulum
overall and then who else are we looking
for here
let's take a look
[Music]
okay we've got 21 gigawatts playing for
enterprise up against edward jones
and oh my god we just came in on a queen
fork look at that that's a nasty one so
paul frowan again looking good for
edward jones so i anticipated that the
lower boards would kind of swing edward
jones's way it looks to be a little bit
more split than that miquez is in in
trouble against pendulum fishers of men
and paul frowan both looking rather okay
though in their games especially paul i
just up a clear queen and actually this
is just checkmate if if white is able to
find this although okay knight c5 does
keep the game going i should say
so not quite uh directly check me just
yet but definitely
looking good
looking good for paul
with that in mind let's jump back to
board one now that they've had some time
to play some moves
got alex with the black pieces we've got
some weird type of
some weird opening it looks like a kind
of a benoni now but we started with one
e4
french sicilian turned benoni really
weird stuff from alex so what's going on
here what's going on well a lot
has gone well for black
uh in the benoni you always have a lack
of space and so it's good if you can
trade off with your minor pieces alex
did manage to hit off the light squared
bishops which is a huge plus
for the moment black also has control
over the e5 square which is also super
super important and black is able to
break through with b5
that being said it's not all bad for
whites we have the strong pawn on d5 as
you always do in the binoni in this last
move bishop takes e5 is also hugely
important for white
this is a very favorable change in
structure for white now black does not
have the e5 square as an outpost for a
strong piece like a knight instead the
pawn on e5 is sort of just serving to
block in black's pieces and so with that
i do think white is going to be slightly
better in this position
but that's just the benoni that's the
benoni life you're always going to be a
little bit worse benoni players are well
aware and they're they're happy with it
they've accepted their their lot in life
okay so let's see what kamikaze knight
can come up with here we've seen all the
games let's just stick with this one and
see what there is to see
okay if i'm playing with the white
pieces here i'm definitely looking at
hops like knight f5 i'm also looking at
moves like rook a6 the queen side is
where things are opening up and so i
want to be
sort of diverting my pieces to that side
of the board
there are other options you can play
something like knight c3 try to jump in
here and okay now i'm just realizing i'm
not in the live position knight c3 was
played knight e4 was played takes takes
and bishop d6 okay so now we're caught
up with the players and kamikaze knight
is still thinking thinking here so he
did go for that plan of planting the
knight on e4
and let's move b4 by the way for black i
really don't like it as black you want
to open things up over here this is your
only source of counter play by locking
it down there's only one open file on
the board and white is in control of it
so really
nothing good in the position anymore for
black
yeah after knight five you can't really
even contest the open a file if you do
you're gonna get captured captured
captured captured and that leaves this
e5 pawn under defended so
really tough really tough here for black
because if you don't contest the a file
rook a6 is going to come in and it's
getting very very nasty there's also
queen g4 threats threatening checkmate
and knight h6 hitting the queen
and yeah those threats i think are the
reason why alex has played g6 here but
of course this this is leaving the h6
pawn behind not to mention
the the other dark squares so looks like
kamikaze knight is is gonna win this one
uh looks like he's gonna win this one
let's jump back though to justini
linguini on board two i kind of liked
his position i thought he had a big
advantage in the center last we checked
and it looks like that big advantage has
turned into an extra knight
so now it should just be a matter
of technique as they say but sometimes
technique is the hardest part of chess
if i'm white i'm going to play rook d1
i'm gonna get on the open file i'm gonna
double up i'm gonna invade i'm gonna
start start uh
making some check mating threats or at
the very least gets uh
get black to trade off some more pieces
make my life a little bit simpler
that being said justini down to two
minutes on the clock down to two minutes
and it looks like fishers of men and
moneyballin might be on their second
game fisher's men did win
that first game really big update there
big update there that being said i think
i want to stick with this justine
linguini game um it might not seem like
that like it's that interesting with
white having more pieces
but you know this king's a little airy
black has this pawn on e4 and justini's
down to two minutes
we do see this move rook d1 though i
think that is the right way to go for
uh for white
and actually the more i look at it the
more it looks like white is is just
going to be crashing through uh if white
can play the move h6 next then rook d8
is actually a checkmate threat which is
is not going to be so comfortable so i'm
confident justine can get this one done
uh
quite confident actually
so looks good for edward jones here
looks good for enterprise on board one
we saw fisher's men take an early lead
in his matchup what else is going on
kendalum has officially won we expected
this results um he had a really good
position lots of uh things were going
well for him over here
but wait what is this resignation
am i missing something
this is a free night
kenjalum hung a knight and then his
opponent resigned
oh my gosh i guess his opponent only
thought he could take with the pawn and
then this was checkmate but like
this is just a free night right this is
just a night
and okay actually i mean
white is still up in exchange after you
take the free night but like come on you
take the free night you keep the game
going
i don't get it but okay kendra who wins
that game regardless
wins that game regardless
and then last but not least we're
checking in on 21 gigawatts against
powell frown
actually are we checking in i guess we
can check in yes so paul rowan did win
that first round game then uh we saw him
up a clear queen it was going to be
enough okay with that let's jump back to
alex here and wow alex better position
than i thought he would have i thought
he was just gonna get checkmated but it
looks like he's just in a
uh well to be fair losing rook end game
uh not all hope is lost though
there's still time there's still time to
do things like try and get active over
here try and make some threats uh try
and push a b-pawn or something
there's not a lot of hope but there is
hope
there is definitely hope here and also
play king g5 king f5 use the king a lot
more easily than white can
so
like i said
not a lot of hope but there is hope
okay i don't actually like this movie
rook c8 i think rookie six is gonna be
leading to some favorable
simplifications okay rookie six isn't
played though at ricky six if you take
then i can take and i win your e5 pawn
by force if you don't take then you lose
your e5 pawn anyways so that's why i
like that move that's why i like king g5
because now against rookie 6 you're able
to capture
go king f5 and then you're actually the
one picking up the pawn
okay white is trying to activate the
king but black's king is going to be a
little bit better here
and with that freedom i would love to
see alex get active you got to go after
white's weak pawns here if you're going
to stay in this game
you have to be willing to give up your c
pawn for the b-pawn that way you get
your own threats can make some trades
and try and survive
see definitely rook a8 has to be played
here
has to be rook a8
yeah g5 that's just not it that's just
not the way to go
yeah now h5 okay it's kind of kind of
weird things going on kind of weird
moves okay rook h8 you're gonna see this
pawn go to h6 now no you're not you're
gonna see rookie six yeah this was a
trap
this was a trick a trick by the tricky
kamikaze knights now after rookie six uh
rook one takes e5 is checkmate and
that's the end of the story i don't have
anything else to say it's checkmate
black's track mated looks bad okay
um checking back in i was confident
justini could win this game it looks
like we are going down to time pressure
though
but yeah bishop a6 is now winning
by force this is double check you can't
even sack the rook for it
can't even sacrifice the rook
okay
justine he sees the mate he sees the
mate
walking the king down the board
so where does that leave us after
one round of play
um if i can
check in it looks like
enterprise has won two of the five games
and edward jones has won three of the
five games so edward jones off to a lead
after that first round of play
off to off to a lead
all right with that why don't we check
back in
on one of the games that's underway
let's check on fishers of men and
moneyballin they finished their first
game rather early so their second game
is pretty far advanced here
and yeah just like in the first game
moneyballin seems to be trying to hang
in there but
it looks like fishers of men was able to
get active first you see these super
active pieces just pressuring everywhere
and with that
all of money ballin's pawns just seem to
be going
you can even give this annoying check if
you want
you don't necessarily okay wait a second
this is a bishop
this is a free bishop
yeah take the bishop
take the bishop
okay he took the bishop
all is correct in the world
looks like a win for fishers and men
looks like a win
okay with that uh let's check in on
kenjalum against mukesh kenjalum the
only other person to score in the first
game other than kamikaze knight for
enterprise so
hoping to get it done again against
miquez
uh in this game though maquez isn't
making it quite as easy as game one he's
attacking on the king side
uh black is breaking through here along
the c file and on d3
but there are some uh are some threats
are some threats to look out for if you
play queen e1 queen g3
your king is looking a little bit airy
just a little bit airy okay queen b1
that feels like the wrong direction
feels like the wrong direction for uh
for mike's your threats lie on the
king's side and you're not able to
really make those threats on this
diagonal the knight just has those
squares covered a little bit too well
that being said i don't understand a6 i
i would take this pawn i would take the
pawn back
queen h4 now but g3 is is going to keep
it under control
and yeah you're kind of just opening up
lines for uh for white here king g2 rook
g7 rook h1
and what's the big idea that's the big
idea
uh it kind of feels like both players
have started playing on the wrong sides
of the board white should be trying to
put all the attention on the king's side
where he has these strong pawns this
extra space and black should be trying
to bring all the attention to the queen
side so white playing queen b1 and then
black bringing all the pieces to the
king's side doesn't make a lot of sense
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
um whenever you have these closed types
of positions you really want to make
sure you are determining the focus on
the side of the board where you're
strong
okay that being said i i missed this
move queen to d2 and that's just winning
material so
uh black did manage to get away with it
it looks like i stand by my words though
i stand by them that's just good chess
knowledge
um okay but this looks good for kendrim
so kendalum the the big scorer now for
enterprise so far
big scorer
we'll stick with this game a little bit
longer see
how things do turn out
yeah i'm already looking for checkmates
though i'm already looking for
checkmates now
as black yeah queen f4
[Music]
looks scary looks scary is it checkmates
is it checkmate you have to play rook g2
here then probably just knight takes e4
yeah probably just knight e4
not so good
not so good
and resigns okay so maquez goes down in
two straight games pendulum gets the job
done when enterprise needs him the most
let's jump now to this matchup we have
chess hulky against justini linguini and
what is going on we have a french
defense
we have
is this
is this the legendary gambit
and this can't be the legendary gambit
it's not the legendary gambit i i
thought i thought for a moment we might
be witnessing um
the legendary milner berry gambit of
youtube fame but it wasn't meant to be
no pawns were gambited it's it's not
scary it's not scary
okay we got bishop g5 on the board now
and what is going on in this position
what's going on here we have the
isolated queens pawn as they say we also
have this structure for black you might
be used to seeing these positions this
pawn back on b7 but this structure with
the pawn on c6 is also not so rare in
some cases it can actually be
advantageous for black to have the pawn
on c6 because it just solidifies the
control over the d5 square so much more
now i'm not convinced that this is one
of those cases um because it does look
like white has meaningful pressure here
and by the way black can't castle king
side and that's just not that's just not
a pleasant thing to deal with not a
pleasant thing to deal with having this
king in the center
so i do think chess loki is on the
better side of things here which is
important because that loss in the first
round is what put edward jones over the
edge that's what gave them
the lead
in round one
so we get queen to d2 now and
the move is passed back to black what
are you going to do
how are you going to solve this king how
are you going to solve this bishop too
many problems
way too many problems
bishop d7 okay that's a start that's a
start
i really don't have the answers though i
keep looking and i'm like do you play f
f6 king f7
and the answer to that question is no no
you don't you just don't do that
um
so what do you do how do you get out of
this
really tough really tough to say
i think you have to go g's and you have
to trade these bishops
then you have to go king f8 then you
have to go g6 then you have to go king
g7 that's the only way that's the only
way to organize your pieces here but
that's obviously
um a lot of moves that you have to play
and it's very very unclear if you have
enough time to do everything
but if i'm justini that's that's the
only plan that i see that's the only way
you're ever getting safe here
rick h8 isn't a bad move it over
protects this h4 pawn a little bit which
is kind of needed
with all this pressure happening against
it all this tension going on not a bad
idea to just add another defender
the question for white though is is how
do you increase the pressure you already
have a lot of pressure on black's
position but he hasn't exactly caved
just yet
so you have to find some way to keep
things moving
bring in another piece bring in a pawn
to help in the attack
what do you do okay bishop e4 is what he
chooses to go with now i'm not certain
that this move actually creates a threat
i don't know if you actually want to
take this piece on d5 it's a good piece
for black but it does sort of fix black
structure
it does fix black
structure just just a little bit
so if i'm black okay
rook h5 is is definitely creative um and
it's probably not a bad move but yeah
i'm still just shaking my head at this
king on e8 i just i want to get him to
safety i want my king to be safer than
this
my king was made for for better things
than sitting on e8
and this is shaping up to be a really
interesting game though justini is
withstanding the pressure just
withstanding it just not giving an inch
okay bishop f4 it might be tempting to
capture this bishop but then this queen
is going to be eyeing some weak squares
okay just he's not tempted he's not
tempted he's playing f or g5 um
yeah i don't know if i can support this
i don't know if i can support this i
might uh
i might have some issues with this way
of playing chess um so you know on the
one hand it makes sense to try to attack
the white king because your king is is
not castled on the other hand you know
it's sort of
a situation where you have to make sure
your house is in order before you go
about uh attacking things and and trying
to checkmate your opponent and black's
house is not in order this rook's out of
the game this bishop's out of the game
this queen is kind of out of the game
this king is weak there's there's no way
you're gonna have a successful attack
here
no way
we got rook back to h8
um and yeah g4 is just an extra pawn now
for white so you know i didn't hate what
justine was doing but g5 is
too much it's too much you gotta you
gotta protect your king gotta protect
your king
now the play for white is going to get a
lot easier want to play g5 you want to
harass this bishop and you want to keep
things open keep things open
okay in the meantime looking at round
two here it looks like worldwide
technology has actually secured victory
in their match against bayer so that's
big news
oh and by the way we do have some more
results fishers of men has won their
game against moneyballin so they are up
to zero
uh kenjalum we did see win his second
game against miquez and paul frowan the
big news has two owed 21 gigawatts
so what's the score at now it looks like
edward jones is at five points and
enterprise is at three
and there are two games left so
enterprise absolutely has to win these
remaining two games in order to tie the
match and that's the best that they can
do enterprise can no longer win the
match even if they win out so this game
is a must win for chess hulky but it
looks like he found g5 and now he's even
breaking through with g6 and i have to
say i like what he's done here i like
what he's done he kept the pressure up
and now he is reaping the rewards yeah
it takes on d5 and look at the
difference between these minor pieces
just look at the difference this is this
is busted
so we turn our attention to alex kurford
it's up to alex if he can walk away with
a measly half point a measly half point
then edward jones wins the match against
enterprise if he can't do it if kamikaze
knight remains dominant in his match and
then we we're going to get a tied a tied
match and they're going to split the
points 10 apiece
um let's see what's going on though let
me count the pawns really quick
okay black has an extra pawn black has
an extra pawn just trust me don't try to
count for yourselves
seven to six i did the math
um so alex down upon but you know not
the worst position in the world um
he does have some weaknesses here but he
has some pressure as well can you plant
this rook on some nice squares rookie 5
would be kind of active rookie 3 would
would be more solid
okay c4 i don't know if i can support
this move either
it has
good intentions he wants to open things
up with something like d5 activate the
rooks even further but it is leaving
weaknesses behind and you already know
that black is looking to plant this
knight here on f5
rook f5 instead is is a little bit
simpler it's just a double attack
just a double attack but if i go king h4
now
then if you take i have c5
knight takes f7
it's gonna get gonna get a little crazy
gonna get a little crazy
just a little crazy
yeah so rick takes a5 here makes a lot
of sense but then you're asking for c5
knight f5 knight f7 knight d4
and i'm not so sure i'm not so sure i
think in the at the end of the day
that's going to be good for for black
okay g6 though i i don't like this now
just b4
white's coming through with b4 and he
still has this sort of grip over
everything you know i definitely still
prefer black uh just because i counted
the pawns
but uh white is is making some real
threats here making some real threats
okay c5 i wasn't really happy with this
move i wanted to keep this move in
reserve this is one of those times when
the threat was more powerful than the
execution when the time is right we want
to kick this knight away and jump in
with knight f7 but if we do it too early
then this knight lands on b5 and has
really great access to this pawn on d4
and that's going to cause white some
some problems here you can defend it but
king c6 adds another attacker
and it looks like kamikaze knight slowly
but surely is taking over the game
taking over the game here
yeah just king c6 or even king e7 to
defend the f-pawn
and i think our d-pawn is is just going
to die and he's just going to die
go king e7
ricky iv
ricky rick d5 pawns dead can see it i
don't like this move the king is a
fighting piece i'm going to use the king
actively in the end game
and king e7 would have been great to
defend the f7 pawn instead though king
c8 is is a little bit passive a little
bit passive
okay rookie four by alex is defending
and see now i would love to play rick d5
and just win this pawn outright but i
can't because of this pressure over here
now if i had my king on e7 i could do
that
okay e5 was what he wanted to go for but
i don't really get it uh just d5 what's
what's the problem just d5 here
i don't know i don't have the answers i
only have the question
um
and i mean d5 is kind of the only move
if you don't play d5 you just lose this
pawn so alex definitely needs to pick up
the pace by the way chess holkey does
get it done in this game wins by
resignations so this
is the pivotal game and if i'm not wrong
i think it's the last game
we see alex kurford in the hot seat
again with the last game
of the day
oh i might be wrong there might be one
more between oak ave and i love legos
too is that true that is true but that
game's going to probably finish first
alex no alex this loses a piece buddy
this loses a piece
what is he doing ah that's
some bad tactics there some bad tactics
losing a piece
um yeah now you just take on on d4 even
if white were to win both of these pawns
for free uh it's not enough the f pawns
aren't going anywhere and
looks bad for alex checking in over here
um looks good for oak f okay there's
time and pieces so we'll stick with this
one
but i don't think it's meant to be
i don't think it's meant to be
um
okay and i think we are actually going
to take a quick break here as we wait
for these games to to wrap up so stay
with us we will be back before too long
so it's event three of the fall 2021
corporate chess league 2020 champions
enterprise has raced to the lead in the
grand prix standings but they're up
against a familiar foe tonight reigning
champion edward jones
which corporation will have the upper
hand tonight find out now
all right hello and welcome back um i
was just saying we are wrapping up here
alex curfert is the last one remaining
he's trying to walk away with a half
point in order to uh
win the match for edward jones but he
cannot do it and again we see edward
jones and enterprise actually tying in
their
match really crazy stuff uh if you're
just joining us this is the 2021
corporate chess league my name is caleb
denby and we just had a very exciting
couple of hours here going over and uh
commentating on
chess games from local
st louis corporate people uh they're in
a chess league they play each other uh
in teams and speaking of that uh with
this game now finishing alex does resign
and so we will take a quick look at the
results and see how we did today
so
with that loss uh kamikaze knight
secures the tie in the match for
enterprise against edward jones both of
those teams walking away with 10 grand
prix points and in the other matches
worldwide technology bounces back after
that loss in round one defeats bayer and
is able to get those 20 grand pre points
and then in the ascension versus darty
match we saw ascension actually getting
it done against doherty dardy was off to
a strong start in round one c cell of
603 in particular playing some really
impressive chess but round two it wasn't
meant to be ascension gets the win and
let's see where that takes us to our
standings for the night it looks like
edward jones and enterprise are the big
winners uh with a pretty even split of
the points here of course they tied
their match they each get 10 grand pre
points and then moving down the list
worldwide technology still defending
their position nicely with 32 and a half
points tonight and dardy with a good
night over 26 points and ascension with
25 and a half points not such a great
night for bayer
but that's all right now how's this
going to affect our grand priest
standings
these were the standings coming into the
night so edward jones is going to make
up some ground up against worldwide
technology uh fighting for that second
place spot in enterprise the big winners
tonight are going to maintain their
first place lead with that big win over
worldwide technology and round one they
will not be dethroned here tonight
um and with that i think we are going to
call it a night here in st louis
thank you for joining if you just joined
from the u.s champs broadcast you caught
us in the final few minutes of our show
but it's a lot of fun uh we'll be here
back not next thursday but i believe the
thursday after that if you want to catch
the show
more live
as always thank you to all the
corporations and players that we're
playing if you yourself are local to st
louis and want to get involved with the
corporate chess league you can send us
an email at development
stlouischestclub.org
we would be happy to have you in the
league with all that said
i have been caleb denby this is the
corporate chess league thank you so much
for watching and i will see you next
time
you